hello everyone I just bought this book
it's called McHale towels best games and
this is only the first part of the book
it's a trilogy this is the magic of
youth covering games from 1949 to 1959
the book is written by Ibaka Rowley or
his Hungarian so maybe it's Tibor karoli
an international master and also
renowned chess author and the trainer so
as I'm going through the book um as I
you know find an interesting game or an
interesting story I'm probably gonna
share it on my channel and make a video
about it so this game this game was
played this is probably the first game
recorded I mean ever played by tall I
was played in 1949 in Riga tall was 12
years old at the time and well this is
this was played in a simultaneous
exhibition ratmir home of a well-known
chess master was holding the exhibition
and the wall tile was one of the
participants of the exhibition and coma
was a really strong chess master at the
time later he will become one of the
world's strongest grandmasters
throughout his career mr. Komarov
played I really seven or eight world
champions and he played over fifty over
I believe about 52 games against world
champions winning seven and drawing 34
and losing 12 games so not a bad score
against world champions but this game he
has the white pieces against 12-year old
Michael Tao and well as this is tall's
probably not the first game recorded but
probably tells great first victory hence
the title of the video the star is born
so as I said kool Moe has the white
pieces and he plays c4 we have e six
Knight to c3 D 5 D four so the Queens
gambit declined
we have c6 Knight to f3 and Knight to f6
tall goes for the semi slap defense and
he tall often used the same slub defense
in his younger days but later he would
completely stop playing this but he will
pick it up again later
as he gets older Bishop to g5 and here
tall goes for D captures on c4 he
preparing the very sharp of Botvinnik
variation we have E for b5 tau goes
sorry como goes for a 5 and while this
night isn't really trapped here top
plays h6 and this is the first in
accuracy by by writing the Cole move the
chess master he plays Bishop captures on
f6 were attacking the Queen better here
would be well as you the pieces are
gonna be exchanged so better here is
maybe better to h4 and then after g5 and
Knight captures and g5 h captures and
then Bishop captures on g5 and next move
or whenever you feel like it you will
grab the piece and well this is
considered to be better for white but
okay after h6 maybe Botvinnik variation
wasn't really known in 1949
so homo played Bishop captures on f6g
captures on f6 he captures on f6 and
here tall doesn't recapture immediately
although he is a very he is of young age
he prefers development the material so
he was for Bishop to b4 pinning that
night and not allowing it John 3:4
Bishop to e2 and now tall captures the
pawn Queen captures on f6 home of
castles and we have Bishop captures on
c3 and this well this definitely is a
inaccuracy by Tao probably better would
be to develop the knight with Knight to
d7 or or something but this is given up
a pretty strong dark square bishop and
also strengthening white's d4 pawn but
okay without played Bishop captures on
c3 we have big captures on c3 and the
nafta and outer plays Knight to d7 not
allowing this white knight to jump to e5
we have a for Bishop to b7 and now now
calm of does play Knight to e5 he he
sacrifices another pawn thinking that
the initiative alone will be enough
against the twelve-year-old boy but he
was well mistaken
topless night captures on e5d captors on
e5 and Queen captures on e5 and well
tallies up two pawns now even though he
wasn't really going for material
material in the game
Bishop to f3 now now with ideas of a
capture some b5 and here talkin capture
this c3 pawn which does seem like a very
juicy point it creates a very strong
past c4 pawn but again tall isn't
interested in material he goes for up to
d8 would attempt on the Queen comb of
goes Queen to c2 and this Queen City
Queen to c2 isn't a particularly good
particularly good move as for example
Queen to be one would be a much better
move as it really puts pressure on the
b5 pawn and well now this B pawn cannot
move as this Bishop is will will fall
but okay after rook dat played Queen c2
and here top plays rook to d3 adding
more pressure to the c3 pawn and well
other than this there is also another
threat but a Como well pretty naive if I
might say so I played a captures on b5
totally disregarding stalls a real
threat which is rook captures an f3 and
this is what Tull plays and well G
captures and f3 isn't really possible
como played rook captures an a on a 7 if
he did capture the rook with the G
captures an f3 this is what follows
group the g8 with check acting to h1 and
now C captures on b5 opening up this
beautiful diagonal for this light
squared Bishop and the white is getting
check mated very soon there is nothing
really black can do here white can do
here
so after rook captures on f3 Komal
played rook captures on a7 now
threatening that b7 Bishop and tau goes
for Queen captures and b5 and although
this bike is still better after Queen
character some b5 rook captures and c3
would be would be a more precise move
but okay top lady Queen captures on b5
and here KOMO
really blundered at the game away as
well
if como played rukka capture some be7
after queen capture some b7 and G
captures on f3 tal would still be better
but well you know 12 year old versus a
versus a really good chess master he
would have to work to win this game
being only a pawn up but after this
Queen to b5 idea errata Mirko move
played G captures an f3 which allows me
Hotel - checkmate his opponent in five
moves and this is exactly what towel
does he plays Queen to g5 would check a
king - h1 and here he plays rook to g8
and there is no defense against
checkmate with best defence its mate in
three moves
for example rook to e8 would check but
this is only prolonging the game Bishop
captures an eight
Queen to g6 and after rook captures h4
and Queen captures on h4 but there's
really no point in making any of these
moves
so after rope the g8 of course the the
known chess master rata Mira como
resigned the game and the towel was
victorious hence the star was born
and it's interesting no one really knows
not even the author of the book if thou
prepared this variation with his coach
was it really a preparation for Komal
it's a safe bet to say that it was but
then again who knows and maybe Todd just
had a had a great day so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mark Hartzler for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and I
will probably do a couple more videos
about tau as I go through this book see
you soon